- Hello, and welcome to "Ed
Talks with Khan Academy".
Thank you for joining us today.
I'm Kristen DiCerbo,
the Chief Learning Officer at Khan Academy
and I'm excited today to
talk with Nick Ferroni
who's going to talk about
what would it look like
if we really appreciated teachers?
I'm excited to get on with that.
Before we get started a couple reminders.
First, at Khan Academy, we are a nonprofit
and we rely on donations
from folks like you
to keep doing the work we are.
If you go to khanacademy.org/donate,
you will find a place where
you can easily contribute
and help us continue to
work towards our mission.
Second, we wanna thank
some of the supporters
who have helped us address
the COVID-19 crisis,
including AT&T, General Motors and Fastly.
And finally, if you are
interested in listening
to this discussion or any
other discussions that I've had
or Sal has had with some of our
"Homeroom" and "Ed Talk" guests,
you can go to "Homeroom with Sal"
at wherever you get your podcasts
and hear audio versions of these chats.
So with that, let me
welcome Mr. Nick Ferroni.
Nick, thanks for joining us today.
- Thank you so much for having me, Kris.
I'm just finishing my
school day currently.
- Yes, so let me tell folks
a little bit about you.
You are a high school
teacher who teaches math
and cultural studies and mentor
a diverse group of students,
including founding your school's GSA,
Gay Straight Alliance and Feminist Club.
And I'll brag on you a little bit.
Nick was named one of
100 Making A Difference
for his commitment to education reform,
and has also recently
been named as...
Oh, I lost my place there.
As well as recently named
the Upstander of the Year
by the Human Rights Campaign.
I like that title, Upstander of the Year,
for your advocacy and
support of LGBTQ youth.
So welcome and it is a
pleasure to talk to you today.
- Well, thank you so much.
And history and cultural studies
are definitely my expertise
but thank you, thank you
so much for having me.
It's so great to be here.
I've been looking forward to this so much.
- Great, so I like to
start by asking people
about their career path.
Did you always wanna be a teacher?
How did you come to be
where you are today?
- Wow, that is such an
interesting question.
I always joke around and
say as a kid I wanted to be
a superhero, a philosopher,
a philanthropist,
a comedian, an actor, and an adventurer,
so I became a teacher.
It's kind of like-
- There you go.
- (indistinct) school
all encompassed in one.
I had amazing educators growing up.
Teaching was not my major focus.
I always kind of thought
I wanted to be a mentor,
a coach in that field.
I went to Rutgers to play
football and I majored in history.
At that point, that's kind
of when I started to realize
maybe education and history was kind of
what I would wanna pursue.
Indiana Jones was probably
one of my biggest influences.
I'm like, "If I can do that,
"if I could go on
adventures in the weekend
"and be a professor."
But it's after college, ironically enough,
I ended up acting.
I was actually waiting for a teaching job
to open up in my old high school,
which I had been teaching at
my alma mater now for 19 years,
which is such an interesting
experience in itself.
But I was waiting for a teaching job.
My cousin's a big agent, so she was like,
"Let me send you on some castings
"and make you some money while
you're waiting to teach."
I ended up booking a few jobs,
I ended up on a soap opera,
and I started to do that while
I was subbing in my school.
So I ended up to work more and more.
I mean, I wasn't a big time
player, I was a 10 and under
which meant I had a few
lines every so often.
And eventually they
had me on more and more
and I was getting more opportunities.
And then a teaching job opened
up at my old high school.
So I had to pick between
pursuing something
that I wasn't really passionate about
and I wasn't trained in,
I didn't think I would ever be good at,
I definitely had imposter syndrome
or become a high school teacher.
The irony being that
I went from putting on
one show a day to six shows a day
to an audience that
does not wanna be there.
I will say this with absolute certainty.
Every great teacher
could be a great actor,
not all great actors
could be great teachers
because our job is so performative
and it's so about engagement,
but I now find myself in my 19th year
teaching in my alma mater.
It's the greatest job in the world.
If teaching was my only job
it would be the easiest job in the world,
but there are so many other facets.
And so that's how I'm back
here now at Union High School.
- I love that acting is the thing you do
until a teaching job opens up.
That's (laughing) a
great way to think about
the potential hierarchy of
careers that we think about.
So you said you had some great teachers
and it's Teacher Appreciation Week,
which we'll talk some more about,
but given that, do you
have a teacher or two
that you'd like to specifically point to
as influential for you?
- God, luckily I was very
fortunate to have so many.
I mean, my history teachers growing up
just made me passionate about history.
Passionate people make you passionate.
But I would say whenever
I talk about anything,
I always talk about Mrs.
Martino, my kindergarten teacher,
and she to me was the
epitome of educators.
I came from a very Catholic upbringing,
so being lefthanded,
my Italian grandmother
was not very happy about that.
She would constantly try to
force me to be right-handed.
And obviously as a kid
that's kind of traumatic
'cause you feel like
something's wrong with you.
And then Mrs. Martino
was the one who got me
to embrace being lefthanded.
She would read me books
about left-handed people.
And the irony being I
always tell these stories
whenever I do any press.
I do a lot of press for
obviously in reference to being
an educator and to advocate for teachers.
I always tell the stories
about how Mrs. Martino,
I would have the toughest
days of my life as a student
coming in, and she would always
nurture me and read to me.
And then one day in
particular, I always say how
I was having such a rough day
because my grandmother again
was forcing this kind of
on me to be right-handed
because left-handed was
sinister in her mindset.
She brought me over to
the toy box and she said,
"I want you to pick your favorite toy."
And of course being a kindergarten student
I reach in and grab the
He-Man action figure.
She let me keep it.
It was the greatest moment in my life.
So I always tell the story
on how teachers are so good
at knowing what their
students need emotionally.
The irony being Mrs. Martino
and I have kept in touch
on social media, on Facebook.
So whenever I do a story, Kristen,
I'll always send her a link to it.
I didn't see her since I was her student.
So I always send her the links
and I always get the same response,
"I am so proud of you, I love you so much,
"say hi to your mom."
And finally I did "The Today
Show" and I told the story
about how my kindergarten
teacher, Mrs. Martino
let me keep this He-Man action figure
and it was such a simple act,
but it meant so much to me.
And she replied back to me,
"I love you so much, I'm so proud of you.
"It means so much that
you think so much of me,
"but I have to be honest with you."
So you'll know where this
story's going because
in the history of histories,
I don't think a woman has ever
told a man in any situation
that she has to be honest with them
and something good has come out of it.
(Kristen laughing)
I don't think you've ever sat
down your husband or spouse
or partner and said, "We need to talk,"
and it be something positive.
So I messaged her back and I
was like, "Is everything okay?"
Of course, I mean about her.
And she's like, "Well, I
need to be honest with you.
"I just, I wanna clear something up."
And I am who I am
because of the confidence
that this woman built
when I was a young child.
My mom's amazing, but
Mrs. Martino just added
that confidence and that empowerment.
My thought was, "Is she gonna tell me
"that I wasn't a talented kid
"and I was annoying-"
- Oh, no.
- "and I kind of shocked her?
"Like, 'Nick, I have to be honest.
"'You really blew me away.
"'I thought you'd turned
out to be nothing.'"
I was waiting for that response.
And so she's typing,
my heart's beating 100 miles an hour
because the woman who I
am who I am because of
is gonna crush me at any moment.
So she's typing.
And again, I'm in my 30s
when this is happening.
So my kindergarten
teacher is gonna destroy
a 30 year old man's ego in a heartbeat.
And finally her comment
comes up and she's like,
"Nicholas, I love you so
much, I'm so proud of you,
"but you keep telling people
"I was your kindergarten teacher.
"I was your preschool teacher.
"And you keep saying it
was a He-man action figure
"and it was a Fonzie doll."
And of course I go back and
I text my mom like, "Mom,
"do you remember the toy that
Ms. Martino let me keep?"
And she's like, "What, that weird little
"Fonzie action figure?"
And I was like, "It was a Fonzie doll."
So to me, 30 years later, this
woman remembered the moment,
the day, even the toy.
I felt the only, only logical
response was to surprise her
and go see her.
So that is a picture-
- Oh.
- of me surprising Mrs.
Martino 30 years later.
She opened the door, she started
crying, I started crying.
It was pretty intense.
The other thing I wanna point out
to elementary school teachers,
you are the most patient
people on the planet,
'cause you have to wait 30 years
to find out if you did a good job.
So I get immediate gratification
being a high school teacher
but yes, please don't wait 30 years
to thank your elementary school teachers
on how amazing they were.
But it's like that's one of the moments,
and it was just such an
amazing moment for me
because it's Teacher Appreciation Week.
It's never too early to thank a teacher
who impacted your life
but it can be too late.
So I always encourage people
to not wait for that moment,
to take advantage of it.
But yeah, Mrs. Martino to me
is who I try to be as an educator.
Every student walked in
the classroom feeling loved
and she would always tell
me, and she'd always say,
"They will forget what you teach 'em,
"but they will never forget
how you made them feel
"when they were in your
classroom, in your presence."
And that's something as a
teacher has become my mantra.
- That was my takeaway, part of my
one of my takeaways from that too
was you didn't remember the detail.
You actually didn't even
remember which grade she taught,
but you remembered the way she
made you feel and so I think-
- I also might've suppressed-
- that's the example.
- I might have also suppressed
the fact it was a Fonzie doll.
He-Man's a lot cooler.
Like even that fact,
(Kristen laughing)
that detail of the fact
that she remembered.
But yeah, it's she remembered
those moments and I didn't
but it's I just remembered
how loved and how much I felt.
- Yeah. Yep.
And the confidence that it gave
you, that she gave you too.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
I love it, love the fantastic story.
I'm gonna key in on one
other piece you mentioned
was reading books that made you feel like
you were seeing yourself in the book too,
which is another thing
that I feel is so important
for folks to be able to see themselves
and get that from books, I
feel like is such a gift.
- Well, children's books, I mean,
I don't think people realize
the impact they have,
not only for children to see themselves,
but for other children
to see other children
and to see different
groups and see diversity.
And it's like, I mean, it's
and she was so incredible
way before our time,
way before the inclusive
nature we live in,
she read books on every group, everything,
children with disabilities,
different races.
And it was such a powerful
lesson, it's like...
And I mean, I am the person I am
because of the empathy and
compassion and understanding
that was instilled on me at that time.
And I think that's why it's so important
that educators are supporting that,
are providing inclusive books.
And there are so many amazing
children's books out there,
which everyone has seen.
And the sad reality is I can
imagine that there may be
some classrooms where there are
students who don't feel seen
because they don't have
access to those sort of books
or hear those stories.
- Yeah. Yeah.
So that was a great
tribute to your teacher.
Let's get into this idea of
Teacher Appreciation Week.
You've been very vocal that
there shouldn't even be
a Teacher Appreciation Week.
Tell us why you feel that
way and what your stance is?
- Well, I mean, I think
everyone should be appreciated.
I mean, we shouldn't have Mother's Day.
You shouldn't need a day
to appreciate your mothers,
but we do, we need that reminder.
And then I go back to annoying my mom
the 364 days of the year.
When it comes to professions,
and people have said this for a long time,
if you have an appreciation week,
you're probably not being appreciated.
And it's kind of that celebration
or it's everyone likes to be
appreciated on a larger scale.
When it comes to Teacher
Appreciation Week,
I'll be honest, I used to
be, pardon my language,
but I used to be that
toxic positive person
where you always have to
be positive regardless.
You can't address any negatives.
You can't show any vulnerability.
It always has to be a
positive, positive focus
definitely as an educator.
At the same time you can still be positive
and be understanding and empathetic
and also try to push for change.
And when it comes to
Teacher Appreciation Week,
it's such an interesting thing
because it made me reevaluate
my whole profession.
It also made me reevaluate on
if teachers are really appreciated?
Which kind of I'll be honest,
when I was thinking of ways
to amplify teacher stories
and teacher concerns this year,
one of my thoughts was maybe we should do
an anti-Teacher Appreciation Week campaign
where it's get rid of
Teacher Appreciation Week
for other things.
And obviously I kind of
drifted away from that
because it's still a nice gesture
and it's still nice to be recognized.
Then I kind of came up with the thought of
maybe we should just allow
an open-ended question
of Teacher Appreciation Week is great,
but what if we really
appreciated teachers?
If we appreciated teachers,
what do we need to change?
And not that we're not
appreciated, but at the same time,
what we want to change within the system
and within our professions.
So that kind of led me
to push a little campaign
where I wanted people to
share not only teachers,
but anybody who's supportive
of public schools and education
and education in general,
to just share what they feel
needs to change for teachers
to truly be appreciated.
- [Kristen] So tell us
about that, this hashtag,
#ifweappreciatedteachers, what is that?
What does it become?
- It's to me, it's awareness.
Obviously tweets and posts and hashtags
don't change society,
don't change culture,
but I always feel like,
and as a history teacher
I've always found that
change doesn't happen without awareness
until you bring awareness to things.
It's even as a person when I realized,
became aware of certain
things, it made me more active
to help change the
things that I can change.
And something as simple as
#ifweappreciatedteachers
was just an opportunity to
give educators and everyone
a point to share what they
feel needs to be changed,
not only so that teachers
feel appreciated,
so that we could be better
teachers for our students,
we could be better
partners for our spouses,
we could have certain
resources and certain needs met
so we don't continue down
this, I hate to say it,
but this possible struggle
of a teacher attrition
that will leave schools
without enough educators
to make sure that every student
has a teacher in front of them.
So I reached out to as
many people as I could,
as many educators, and
there was great feedback
and great responses,
and just great thoughts.
And some of 'em I never
thought about, 'cause again,
being a man, I did not think about...
I'm aware of paid maternity,
but I never thought about
how much it affects
the teacher profession,
because we are a profession
predominantly of women.
So it was great to see
everyone's responses.
It was hopefully useful in
the way of making people
more aware of what we're concerned about
that when we go on social
media, we're not complaining.
Me confiding about the stresses of my job
is not complaining about my job,
it's wanting to be a better person,
so I could be better resourced
and a better teacher for my students.
Teachers, when you help
teachers, you help students.
It is not either or.
You don't support students,
and then for you're not
supporting teachers.
Or if you support teachers,
you don't support students.
We are intertwined.
So I just wanted to do something like this
to help bring more
awareness to the concerns,
not only in America, but just
globally and internationally,
because there's a lot of common concerns
that teachers are struggling with.
And I just wanna fix it
before we lose so many amazing educators,
which I'm afraid might happen.
- So we saw on the screen
there some of the responses
that teachers and all sorts
of folks were posting.
Do you have your own list?
What would your list be if we
really appreciated teachers?
- I mean, my list is always probably
the most simplistic list.
It's always kind of the core needs
that I'm in my 19th year as a teacher,
there's not a single year I
haven't worked an extra job.
There was years I was working
three jobs on top of teaching
on top of doing my main job.
I always say teaching's one
of the most important careers
that you have to work other careers
in order to still do your first career.
If you were about to get heart surgery
and you found out your
doctor was driving Uber
for 12 hours before the heart surgery
you'd be a little suspicious
or cautious or concerned.
If you found out your
airline pilot was again,
working in a Target or
working in a factory
right before they were
about to fly the plane,
you'd be concerned.
I mean, I feel the same
way about teachers.
We expect so much and we
give them what's so little.
So obviously the fact that we
don't wanna be millionaires.
It'd be nice if we were,
but just a livable wage
where we can not only live,
but support a family if needed.
That's why I always feel like most men
go into administration
because it pays better.
As a man I could not
support a wife and a child
on my teaching salary,
which is also another problem
which exposes education.
The fact there's it's
predominantly a female profession
that we don't value the work
of women as much as we do men.
And so the idea of paying
teachers a livable wage.
You shouldn't be working an
extra job if you're an educator,
unless it was by choice.
If you want to, that is fine.
It shouldn't be a necessity.
The fact that we buy our own supplies
and we beg for supplies online
to me is still one of
the most insane things.
I love resources and sites that
allow teachers to crowdfund,
but at the same time,
we shouldn't have to.
If every teacher who
is crowdfunding online
was standing on a street
begging for supplies
that would be national
news every single day.
So educators shouldn't be expected
to buy the resources that
they're not provided with.
And we shouldn't be expected to...
At least if we do spend our money,
we should be fully protected.
I'm sorry, the sensor light went out
which happens in a school,
so I'm gonna move real quick.
- [Kristen] Sitting in
one position for too long,
I understand-
- I know. I know.
- [Kristen] in the room.
- I'm pretty animated, I'm
Italian, my hands should be
enough for these sensors
to keep going, but-
- I married an Italian and inherited
some of those hand movements.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So I get it.
- In my day,
these lights used to be a little
more obviously on the sensor side,
but when it comes to the resources,
the fact that it's expected of educators
and the fact we do it and people are like,
"We should stop doing it, but
we could continue to do it,
"but fight for the need so
we don't have to do it."
So, and even just something simple.
I think the pandemic,
we went from being
celebrated to being heroes
then to being accused of
just, "Go back to work,
"we need people to babysit."
We weren't valued.
We aren't invested in.
And it's I've never seen a
profession so celebrated,
but so demonized or so
undervalued at the same time.
And I feel like with educators,
we just want society to invest in us
the same way we invest in our students.
And that's not asking for more,
that's just asking for enough.
So I feel like those three
things from a public opinion,
the investment, from the resources,
every classroom should be fully resourced.
Every teacher should never
have to come out of pocket.
And every student should have teachers
who have all the resources that they need.
And then just for the fact that
if I only had to work one job,
I would be a better teacher than I am.
And I give my all to teaching already.
So I shouldn't have...
Again, it just, it breaks
my heart to show this,
but my Grubhub driver of weeks ago
he's wearing an NJEA shirt,
which is our union in New Jersey.
And I asked him, I'm
like, "Are you a teacher?"
And he said, "Yeah. How'd you know?"
And he looked down and we started talking.
And I was like, "Do you wanna do this?"
He said, "No, I come right from school.
"I teach till 4:00, and
then I come right here
"and do this till 6:00."
And he's a new father, he has to do it.
People should be as angry about that
as they should anything else?
So just more support.
You don't have to have a child
to support schools and education.
I think education's the only investment
that really benefits everybody.
Outside of universal healthcare,
education is the next best investment
that benefits everybody.
I'm sorry for that kind of
emotional rollercoaster ride,
but it's just, yeah,
it's like my Uber driver
and talking to him and just seeing that,
it's like it's heartbreaking.
And it's and he's not the only one.
Majority of a lot of
teachers, a lot of teachers
tend to work extra jobs
just to supplement.
- Yeah.
The other thing that I know from teachers
that are in my family
and that I know is that
if they're not working another job,
they're working their teaching job,
weekends and evenings and
doing all of that work.
How do you feel like we
should address that piece
where there's so much
on the teacher's plates?
- Well, anybody who says
teachers only work days
and have evenings and
weekends and summers off
doesn't know any teachers.
And the running joke,
somebody tweeted this.
They're like, "Saying teachers
only teach during school days
"or work during school days is like saying
"Tom Brady only works 15 Sundays a year."
Because that's when he actually works
as if he's not working every other day
preparing and everything else.
If we were paid by the hour,
going back to being a millionaire,
we would be millionaires if we were paid
by the actual hour of work we
do because there's so much.
And the irony being,
if I would never encourage
a national strike,
at the same time part of me feels like
if educators only did
their contractual job,
the education system would fall apart.
If we didn't do the beyond,
the extra hour work,
the working on the weekends,
we wouldn't be able to do our job,
but I feel like the education system
would absolutely crumble.
It is almost impossible to
fulfill our duties as educators
within our contractual hours.
We're expected to work outside of them.
And if we don't, nothing will get done.
So we almost feel obligated
to do it because again,
we don't wanna punish our students
because we are not allotted
enough time to get papers,
lesson planning, professional development
done within the school day.
- So what is the solution for that?
Is it that we need more
teachers so that any individual
teacher has less of a workload?
Or what is the...
How do we help fix this?
- Well, I mean, it's no
teachers should have a class,
especially elementary school
of over 15 or 20 students.
I mean, the fact there's
kindergarten teachers with 30 or 40
absolutely blows my mind.
I have high school students
in classes of 30 as well.
To me, it's impossible
to develop relationships
with students when you have class sizes...
I'm sorry.
Gordon.
- Yes, sir.
I'm recording a video.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
- It's all right. Thank you.
- I'll come back.
- All the interruption-
- Students coming in
all the time.
- (indistinct) students, yep.
This is the perfect...
I just need one announcement
and one student to walk
in with a late pass,
even though there's no students
just to show you what happens
on a regular school day.
- That is great.
- This is not planned, this
is all life of a teacher.
- This is all life of a
teacher, totally understand.
You mentioned, we showed
some of the things
that other teachers have said,
and also you shared your thoughts.
Can people still
participate in the campaign
and share their thoughts about this?
- Absolutely.
We have a template, a blank template,
#ifweappreciatedteachers.
And if you are a parent, if
you're an advocate, if you just,
if everybody has a
teacher in their family,
just share, fill in the blank,
it's an open-ended question.
Share what you feel needs to happen
to truly let teachers
know we appreciate them.
And the templates, it's very
simple, it's on my socials.
I believe we'll be sharing
it on here as well.
So we'll sharing-
- It's going to be
in the chats for you that
are watching this, yeah.
- Yes, it'll be in the chat
for obviously this video.
And all you're gonna
do is just make a copy.
Very simply insert what
you think needs to happen
for teachers to be appreciated,
truly to be appreciated.
And then share it and use that hashtag.
And let's just keep awareness.
This conversation can't end
after Teacher Appreciation Week,
because obviously we're
still in the school year.
We'll be back to school next year.
We can't come out of these
past two years without making
some change for the better in
education and for educators.
So all I ask is take three minutes
to think of what you need
think needs to happen,
and share it, and just kind
of join this little movement
and help bring awareness
to people who may not understand education
or have connections to teachers.
- Great.
We have a number of parents
who often engage with us.
What kinds of things can parents do
to both support classroom
teaching practices
or in the ways they
talk to their students?
- Well, I would say, I mean, parents,
my heart goes out to you as well
because we are in this together.
It is not parents versus teachers.
We wanna see your child succeed so much.
We wanna work with you.
Which I hate when parents and teachers
tend to get politicized
and put against each other.
But as parents, reach out
to your child's teachers,
and as teachers reach out
to your students' parents,
and just find out what we
can do to work with you.
And as far as supporting
your classroom as a parent,
find out how many students
are in your child's classes.
Find out if the classes
are fully resourced.
If they're not, show up
to those board meetings,
run for school boards, speak
out in defense of the staff.
Put pressure on school boards, I'd say,
but if you put pressure on a school board,
they will be more inclined
because then they feel like
the community's behind this message.
So be very involved in understanding
on what's going on in the classroom
as far as if your child's in
a classroom of 35 students,
I'd be concerned with that as a parent.
I would think my child's not
getting the best education.
I would then support hiring more teachers
to make sure those
class sizes can go down.
So just work with teachers,
reach out to teachers.
We are here for you.
We want to do whatever we can from our end
to not only support your mission,
but to help what you're doing,
but just also to set
your child up to succeed.
- Fantastic.
So we've talked a lot about
how difficult and challenging
the job of teaching is.
What keeps you inspired?
What keeps you doing this?
- I mean, outside of all the interruptions
and chaos and dysfunction, it's
we had Miss USA come
by our school on Monday
to surprise our students and staff.
And I always use my platform
to get opportunities for my students.
The photographer they hired
to shoot Miss USA's visit
and videotape it was my former student
who I had as a sophomore in class.
My greatest moment as a teacher
was helping him get his
first published photo
on a national magazine which was of me.
And as educators
it's teaching is it's
we enjoy nothing more
than seeing our students
go on to be successful
and pursue what they love
and to be happy, successful,
empowered human beings.
I always say a teacher is
someone who dedicated their life
to the success and happiness
of other people's children.
But seeing my students
thrive, interacting with them
even days when there's battles.
Every day is not rosy with students.
They're emotional beings.
I'm an emotional being.
There are days I don't have my coffee.
I'm a little more irritable
than I would be on a normal day.
So it's just those interactions.
And I will say this
with absolute certainty,
and I know 99.9% of teachers
would agree with me.
If a teacher ever leaves
teaching and a lot of 'em are,
it is not because of the students.
That is the only reason
teachers will endure
what we're enduring and what
we've been bearing for so long
is because we do it for our students.
We did not become teachers for the salary,
the fame or the summers off.
But the fact that it's
interesting enough where
for some of us it's our dream job.
The fact that we have people
leaving their dream job
should tell a lot of people how unbearable
some situations have become.
But it's my students,
it's that interaction,
they keep me inspired.
I'm a better person.
I would not be half the person I am today
if not for having new groups
of students every year
who hold me to a higher
standard, who better me.
It's like that makes me a better person.
- Fantastic.
It has been a pleasure
to talk to you today.
If folks want to hear more from you
or find out what else
are you up to coming up,
what do you have coming up?
- You could follow me on my socials,
Instagram and Twitter is @NicholasFerroni.
I am also collaborating with Kahoot.
I'm hosting a little
live game show for them
every two weeks.
Our first Kahoot game show is tomorrow.
And it's not only for teachers,
it's for teachers, students,
game show enthusiasts.
Our first one's tomorrow
at 3:00 PM Eastern Time
at Kahoot's Instagram.
So join us, it'll be a lot of fun,
but just feel free to message me, DM me,
or reach out if there's
any way I could help.
Especially as educators.
I love sharing the stories
of amazing teachers
and I feel like not enough
people hear those stories.
- Fantastic.
Thanks so much for your time today.
Thanks everyone who joined us
and we will see you next time.
- [Nicholas] Thank you so much.